ladies and gentlemen welcome to the 10
million dollar studio want to do
something a bit different today
i want to share with you guys by the way
we're in the studio and knight of course
came in
had to get in the studio at night you
guys know how it is i want to talk to
you guys
a little bit about some free advice that
changed my life you guys know first of
all how i'm a fan of free things
second of all generally speaking you
know i'm not trying to tell you guys
that i
have the answers but um i'm just gonna
tell you something that helped me out
because i realized the other day that
i've been in the game
the youtube game for seven years
this is actually my first video that i
ever
uploaded right here it was a piano video
and that's seven years ago february 1st
2014.
now it's private and it will stay be
staying that way to be honest
i knew nothing about cameras lighting
anything else now you see me i'm in the
10 million dollar studio you say stephen
you just
maybe maybe you were just born like this
maybe you just know how to make the
stuff because you're
you're you're just gifted the answer is
no it was a long process and i want to
share with you guys something because
the truth is if you're going to do
anything ambitious it is going to take
a lot of time of just being bad
and you have to get comfortable with
that i know that seems counterintuitive
but if you can just cut
get comfortable with the fact that
you're going to fail for a long time
to achieve what you want you can improve
your odds because when i
started youtube i knew that the odds
were stacked against me so i just said
to myself
if i can endure failure for longer than
your average person
my odds go up right there's no
guarantees in life obviously it's a very
hard thing to kind of break into
but uh my odds improve enormously
and so you guys now see the coffee zilla
you see the 10 million dollar studio you
see the lambo and you say stephen you're
this big shot success whatever
uh and the reality is that no it was
just a lot of work in fact
when did coffee break start because
that's when i first like started
to get a little bit of success coffee
break
started three years after my first video
so
in three years i got 400 subscribers
now how do you deal with that how do you
well i'll tell you how i dealt with it
and you you'll find your own way but
this is a video that i've shared
probably i don't know probably 10 times
just this week it's one of my favorite
videos on the internet
and it really helped me when i was
sucking i thought i'd share it with you
guys today maybe you'll get a little bit
of it out of it
maybe not i don't know it's just a
different kind of video this is uh by
the way
who who is this because right we don't
just listen to random people this is ira
glass critter of
this american life it's one of the most
successful podcasts
and he does really interesting stories
but he's about to share with you
about like the gap as we'll call it
nobody uh tells people who are beginners
and i really wish somebody had told this
to me is that um
if you're watching this video you
somebody wants to make videos right
and all of us who do creative work like
you know we get into it and we get into
it because we have good taste
do you mean like you want to make tv
because you love
tv you know what i mean because there's
stuff that you just like love
imagine little coffeezilla watching this
no subscribers
no one's watching i'm trying to ditch
chemical engineering
a stable career path to do youtube
how could i do it this changed my life
okay
so you've got really good taste and you
get into this thing that i don't even
know how to describe but it's like
there's a gap
that for the first couple years that
you're making stuff yeah
what you're making isn't so good okay so
it's not that great it's not
it's not really not that great he's
lying to you it's gonna be worse than
not great it's trying to be good it has
ambition to go but it's not quite that
good
but your taste the thing that got you
into the game your your taste is still
killer
and your taste is good enough that you
can tell that what you're making
is kind of a disappointment to you you
know what i mean like you can tell that
it's still
sort of crappy a lot of people never get
past that face a lot of people at that
point they quit
ding ding ding ding ding ding guys i
would just like say to you with all my
heart
is that most everybody i know
who does interesting creative work they
went through a phase of years
where they had really good taste they
could tell what they were making wasn't
as good as they wanted it to be they
knew it felt short you know
and like and some of us could admit that
to ourselves and some of us are a little
less able to admit that to ourselves but
we knew like
it didn't have this special thing that
we wanted to have
the thing i would say to you is
everybody goes through that and for you
to go through it if you're going through
right now if you're just getting out of
that phase
if you're just starting off and you're
entering into that phase you got to know
it's totally normal and that is the
statement that
completely changed because the idea that
it's normal
to fail over and over and over in the
first
years of getting into anything and by
the way he's talking about creative work
here he's like obviously in radio
i think it applies to everything i think
this advice applies
across the board i think it was mark
cuban who said try to get your first
you know failure in business out of the
way as quickly as possible
if you're going to go into
entrepreneurship in other words it's
normal
it's completely normal to fail
especially when you get started and
so often i feel like the whole if there
was
a a through line with fake gurus it
would be people
trying to take shortcuts in life in
order to find success
faster people trying to find blueprints
for something that
doesn't really have a blueprint i can't
tell you how many times i've told people
what the things i've learned on youtube
and what actually is holding them back
when i watch their videos is just they
haven't put in the time
it's not some magic formula it's just
they haven't made enough
stuff they haven't put enough hours in
and that's what people are always trying
to
uh you know replace i mean the easiest
way to see this is in the gym
you know everyone knows how to get
ripped in the gym it's just work out
the reason most people are not you know
ripped
cut is not because they don't have the
the best trainer in the world it's
because they don't want to put in the
time
you and i both know that and yet for
some reason it feels like this is kind
of uh
hard to find advice these days and why
because you can't sell it nobody's
selling this advice
the most important possible thing you
could do is do a lot of work
that too huge volume of work put
yourself on a deadline so that every
week or every month you know you're
going to finish one
story you know what i mean whatever it's
going to be like you create the deadline
it's best if you have somebody who's
waiting for work for you somebody who's
expecting it
from you even if it's not somebody who
pays you but that you're in a situation
where you have to turn out the work
because it's only by actually going
through a volume of work that you're
actually going to
catch up and close that gap yeah and
that's also something that i really
internalize especially with coffeezilla
i mean
only a year year and change ago i
decided i needed to start not just doing
you know i needed to do more videos i
was putting out a video a month
and i was like that's too slow and uh
coffeezilla
really i started to kind of find my
voice when i started to do
more videos um i don't know if this is
true for everyone i know some people
like to take their time with videos but
that really resonates with me
as far as doing a huge volume of work
and look i know for a lot of you
none of this resonates maybe you don't
care about this maybe you have a job
maybe you don't want to you know do
something kind of off the beaten path
but i also know that a lot of people
do and you hear the stats of you know
how often people fail and you want to
know
how you can give yourself a better shot
well i'm telling you how
i gave myself i feel like a better shot
at least was internalizing this message
and being willing to commit basically
four to five years of very little
success
very little success on youtube until
finally things
i kind of started to figure out you know
how to make videos that are worth
watching if that makes sense and i still
feel like i'm finding that out
every day i mean i've told someone just
the other day like most of my videos are
disappointments to me which is true
and i am committed to making them better
for you that's the purpose of the 10
million dollar studio
that's the purpose of always trying to
change things is because i'm obsessed
with getting this stuff better you know
it's not always going to be about fake
gurus but
my real craft my real passion which is
making videos and entertaining people
um i will always be getting better at
that i don't know if this resonates with
anyone
and it's a different video it's outside
my normal wheelhouse
but uh yeah i just thought i'd share
share with you a little coffeezilla
at night i hope you enjoyed i'll see you
next
a trick trying to time me on a dream but
that was where you lost me
wake up and smell the coffee